alors on vient à un moment assez
difficile mais c'est aussi un moment
assez historique puisque à l'issue de
cette crise il y aura sans doute
beaucoup de chamboulements économique ou
politique et je pense que c'est devenu
plus important que jamais de réfléchir à
des questions éthiques fondamentales à
savoir qu'est ce qu'on veut pour nos
différentes sociétés
qu'est ce qu'on veut pour mieux se
préparer à d'autres événements
similaires dans le futur
et qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour qu'on
ait des sociétés finalement plus
robustes plus résiliente à des crises
comme cela pour que ça se passe bien
même quand quelque chose se passe très
mal dans nos sociétés mais pour bien y
arriver je pense qu'il est devenu plus
important que jamais de mettre en avant
la philosophie morale le raisonnement
éthique et notamment des bons réflexes
pour réfléchir à comment bien réagir en
situation d'urgence
nous n'avons peut-être moins le temps de
prendre le temps de la réflexion et ça
nécessite d'utiliser des outils
indispensables comme à chaque débat tant
mieux et eu énormément de communication
qui ont lieu au cours de ces derniers
jours j'ai eu énormément de débat à
gauche à droite et c'était super
important de faire attention à comment
bien débattre dans ces situations de
crise est également le bail zanis mais
devenu absolument critique
puisqu'on est dans une situation où il
ya énormément d'incertitudes où il ya eu
énormément d'incertitudes et du coup
c'est super important de développer un
langage beaucoup plus probabiliste et de
se rendre compte de l'étendue de notre
ignorance au moment des prises de
décision donc voilà c'est un peu le
cadre global dont laquelle j'ai envie de
cadrer un peu la vidéo d'aujourd'hui et
en particulier pour pouvoir faire une
analyse de comment bien raisonné vous
propose de faire un peu une
rétrospective en vous parlant de dilemme
moreau qui ont lieu au cours de ces
derniers mois autour du cou rona virus
alors bien sûr il ya le cas vraiment
horrible des médecins qui ont dû et qui
vont devoir prioriser les personnes à
soigner aux dépens de deux personnes qui
n'auront pas les soins adéquats
suite à leur maladie en particulier
probablement avec beaucoup de cas de
kovy de 19 à venir et ce sont des
dilemmes absolument horrible mais c'est
pas et 10 m dont j'ai envie de parler
aujourd'hui parce que les dilemme se
pose en fait à chacun d'entre nous et en
particulier au cours des deux derniers
mois j'ai vécu énormément de dilemmes
moraux avec potentiellement des milliers
peut-être des centaines de milliers de
vies en jeu et peut-être même le futur
et comme de nos économies et de nos
politiques donc voilà c'est parce que
c'est important de prendre la mesure de
l'enjeu des dilemmes d'aujourd'hui et de
réfléchir à ce qui aurait pu être mieux
fait il se rend compte que c'est
vraiment vraiment très très très
compliqué
et pour vous présenter les 10e je vais
vous présenter de façon chronologique et
le premier d'entre eux ce sont les
premières communications que j'ai
entendus autour du courroux d'un virus
alors je suis pas quelqu'un qui suit
beaucoup l'actualité de base même je
suis très très très peu l'actualité
donc j'ai été informé pour au sujet du
coronavirus à peu près sans doute après
tout le monde mais j'ai commencé à en
entendre parler
je trouve que la première fois j'ai
regardé un peu mes archives pour
préparer cette vidéo mais la première
fois c'est devaient être des emails de
le pfl qui signalait tv ce problème et
puis ensuite il ya eu cette vidéo de
tania lui qui est techniquement date
d'avant les emails de le pfl mais j'ai
tweeté à son sujet le 30 gw supposer que
je les regardais le 30 janvier puis oui
je suis juste après avoir vu la vidéo
donc je veux pas tu t'es trois jours
après avoir la vidéo et cette vidéo
d'état n'y lui je recommande vivement de
la voir avec le recul non pas parce que
thanyarat fait un mauvais travail dont
je pense qu'à faire un excellent travail
à étant donné l'ensemble des
connaissances qu'elle avait à ce moment
là mais but pour bien des matériels se
rendre compte de la difficulté de se
rendre compte de l'urgence du problème
et en particulier à ce moment là il n'y
avait sans doute pas lieu d'être
enfin paniqué en tout cas il y avait
clairement lieu de surveiller ce qui se
passait mais tout cas d'après tania et
j'ai tendance à faire beaucoup confiance
à la tania qu'elle ait l'air de s'être
énormément informée à ce sujet il n'y
avait pas lieu de se préoccuper beaucoup
plus de cela qu'il y avait lieu de se
préoccuper par exemple de la grippe ou
d'autres potentiel épidémique type h1n1
ou autre donc à ce moment là a priori il
y avait lieu d'être un petit peu prudent
de ce risque qui se passe mais ne pas en
faire plus que ça et ça me semble en
tout cas largement excusé fait qu'il n'y
ait pas eu de prise de décision
gouvernementale à ce moment là pour
préparer l'épidémie à venir à ce
moment-là tout cas d'après cette vidéo
et je ne savais pas beaucoup plus de
toute façon il semblait ne pas y avoir
lieu de faire beaucoup plus que cela en
particulier le dilemme à ce moment là
pour moi c est ce que je m'informe
d'inventaire et jeux sur ce sujet
sachant que c'est un sujet qui est
récurrent dans la sphère altruisme
efficace le sujet des pandémies donc
c'est un sujet sur lesquels j'ai déjà
entendu parlé plusieurs fois en
entendant que c'est un sujet d'être
inefficace et je me sentais un sujet
important qui pouvait peut-être des
millions de vies en jeu et c'est sans
doute encore le cas aujourd'hui
et du coup il y avait un petit peu un
dilemme à ce moment là pour moi d excuse
informe davantage sur cette maladie ou
non et 1 finalement la vidéo de tania
lui masser par mal convaincu que des
gens beaucoup plus compétents que moi
s'en chargent déjà et en plus ya pas
forcément lieu de s'en préoccuper outre
mesure non pas je me suis pas préoccupé
plus de ça avec le recul je pense que
c'était la bonne décision mais bien sûr
ça se discute en tout cas avec les
données que j'avais je pense qu'il y
avait moi c'était la bonne décision il
me semble à ce que ce serait facile avec
le recul de se dire non mais fallait
agir fait secret que de ça mais j'ai
énormément d'autres énormément d'autres
préoccupations et si je me suis je me
suivait notamment sur aube au style
bénéficier vous savez que j'avais des
préoccupations qui me semble beaucoup
plus urgente encore que les pandémies
peut-être pas la semaine dernière mais
petit à petit je pense que déjà le point
de l'esthétique des algorithmes
redevenir la priorité l'a déjà été
d'ailleurs on en reparlera dans cette
vidéo
au cours de cette pandémie
le deuxième épisode et du coup 2e
dilemme éthique que j'ai eus confrontés
c'était vers fin février quand il
commence à y avoir des cas en italie
or l'appareil je suis par l'actualité du
coup j'ai découvert par hasard il y eu
un super trade de tania à ce moment là
le 24 février
mais je pense que je ne les ai pas vues
passer moi ce qui m'a alerté c'était
plus la rencontre de gens qui étaient
vraiment très très préoccupé par cela
donc quand des amis mathématicien et
notamment une amie italienne qui du coup
suivait ce qui se passe en italie de
très près eux étaient très très très
très préoccupé c'est la première fois
qu'on a refusé de me serrer la main
donc c'était les premières mesures de
distanciation social que l'observer et à
ce moment là j'avais l'impression que
ces personnes sur réagit c'est parce que
le nombre de cas à ce moment une qualité
peut être de l'ordre de la centaine et
là c'est peut-être ma première erreur de
ne pas avoir été plus préoccupé par cela
jusqu'en mai ensuite sur un bloc de
billets de blogs de l'altruisme efficace
sur le fond de la crise mais efficace et
toujours faire fin février et cela a été
beaucoup plus alarmiste et je suis un
petit peu plus attiré l'attention tant
que j'ai dans sa sphère assez confiance
à des gens d'altruisme efficace et en
particulier ce poste et les cris a été
écrit par quelqu'un qui qui faisait son
master dans un domaine similaire de m&i
l'équité en particulier très proche des
milieux de biosécurité et son poste
était très très préoccupant en suggérant
tu vraiment un risque de pandémie est
globale et surtout qui a appelé à des
mesures assez forte déjà notamment de
distanciation social mais voire même de
télétravail voire même d'isolation et
notamment des grandes îles qui semblait
assez radicale à cette époque pour fin
février donc ça m'a un peu alerté et
surtout c'était assez en contraste avec
d'autres contenus qui était produit en
france notamment par des sphères du
milieu sceptiques qui avait tendance à
comparer le nombre de cas du virus avec
l'ombre de cale de la grippe et c'est
une coopération qui a été absolument
fait montre on peut puisque le gros
risque du coronavirus c'était sa
capacité à se propager beaucoup mieux
que la grippe est d'être en plus 10
puisque dix fois plus mortelle que la
grippe tout cas à ce moment là il ya
encore beaucoup dans certaines le font
aujourd'hui encore il ya beaucoup
incertitudes sur sur ces chiffres
mais tout ça fait que c'est assez
préoccupant et en plus une
supplémentaire en fait pour le cours
d'un virus qui était difficile à évaluer
à ce moment là qui est difficile à
évaluer si on n'a pas un raisonnement
bayésiens raisonnement probabiliste qui
est le fait ce qui vient encore beaucoup
d'inconnues sur 7 sur ce court aux
navires us que du coup potentiellement
il est encore bien plus horrible que les
estimations que l'on peut avoir fait
jusque là
bref tout ça a fait que j'ai commencé à
être un peu préoccupé par la situation
et je suis sorti de mon silence j'ai
envie de dire sur le coroner a jusque là
j'ai jamais communiquer quoi que ce soit
de sérieux en tout cas sur le court d'un
virus et c'est là que j'ai commencé à
partager publiquement mes inquiétudes en
twittant le biais de blogs dalle très
efficace mais à ce moment là ce qui me
frustre est davantage c'était le manque
de langage probabiliste utilisé par la
plupart des gens que je voyais sur
twitter pas parce que son gage pour la
vie ce que comme j'aime le dire il en
fait assez crucial pour se rendre compte
que le coronavirus ça peut être pour
moins que la grippe mais vu
l'incertitude qu'il a actuellement à ce
moment là c'était encore possible qu'il
ait un effet beaucoup plus grave que le
coronavirus le que le virus de la grippe
et que du coup c'était important d'avoir
son langage probabiliste pour se
préparer notamment à changer d'avis donc
c'est là que j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à un peu plus encore la
grèce mais encore très très très peu et
je ne suis pas vraiment investi dans le
la lecture sur le court malgré son gros
à ce moment là j'avais lu la page
wikipedia et ce billet de blog
d'altruisme efficace et quelques
communiqués de l' oms
et c'est tout je n'ai pas creusé plus
que ça et surtout que j'ai pas réfléchi
plus que ça c'est peut-être une erreur
de ma part
à ce moment-là peut-être qu'ils avaient
déjà lieu de beaucoup plus se préoccuper
de beaucoup plus près par et d'autres
personnes c'est un dilemme éthique à
c'est assez difficile
j'avais beaucoup de chose à faire j'ai
toujours beaucoup de choses à faire
d'autre à cette période également jeu
m'occuper du coup un virus j'ai un job
aussi c'est à dire j'ai des vidéos à
faire je pense que base à nice mais
c'est important façon générale je pense
qu'en est il des algorithmes à ces ultra
important j'étais un peu attention et ça
me semblait pas encore être la priorité
peut-être que c'était une erreur a
posteriori de me dire que vu à quel
point les gens se préparaient peut
s'asseoir peut-être dû me pousser à
m'intéresser davantage au corona lloris
donc c'est peut-être la première erreur
éthique que j'ai fait
première d'une longue série mais
heureusement
et donc finalement il m'a fallu tout
mais nathan de la semaine du 2 mars pour
m'intéresser un peu plus au problème du
courant navires us grâce notamment à des
discussions informelles avec des amis au
laboratoire notamment et qui est
biologiste et qui a pas mal d'amis en
épidémiologie et qui lui a été assez
enfin très préoccupé déjà et à ce moment
là on a commencé à engager des
discussions sur sachant que la période
d'incubation commencer je commençais à
prendre tous arrêtés sur le cours de
clôture à sion et tout ça sachant que la
période d'incubation pouvait être très
très longues
donc je pense que les discussions a été
un peu extrême mais on va dire sur
certains aspects en tout cas ce qu on a
beaucoup parlé du cas on a deux semaines
d'incubation
du coup c'est le chiffre que j'avais
gardé en tête d'ailleurs ça se voit dans
la vidéo que j'ai fait du du 11 mars du
9 mars mai puis on s'était dit si sa vie
à cette période de deux semaines et que
ça eu lieu en italie l'italie c'est pas
très loin de la suisse c'est juste de
l'autre côté des montagnes
en direction de bâle s'est dit peut-être
il ya déjà pas mal de cas en suisse et
en particulier à lausanne est en fait
certains étaient assez paniqué et
certains qui estiment et profiter de tes
avoir déjà le coroner virus à 10% ce
qu'est ce que je ferais complètement
beaucoup trop mais du coup on a commencé
à parler voilà j'ai poussé un peu plus
les gens avoir un langage progrès liste
et petit à petit la question de savoir
comment estimer la probabilité d'avoir
le courant navire est soi même est
devenu quelque chose d'assez intéressant
et c'est ça qui m'a tirée avec attiré
mon attention à ma priorité à ce moment
là c'était encore promouvoir le belize à
nice mme attaques de bateaux mieux et
l'éthique des algorithmes il a en fait
ça tombait très bien dans hashtag doit
être mieux les bases à nice mme ça fait
2 sur 3 et en plus sa part d'un suivi et
d'un culte et et en plus ça permet de
contribuer à la préparation aux
coronavirus aussi voir oui il faut que
je fasse une idée au fait c'est pas
l'idée ne vient même pas de moi m'a dit
qu'il fallait que je fasse une vidéo
effet au oui c'est vrai que ça qu'elle
s'accroche pas mal de cases et du coup
j'ai réfléchi ça se fête le mercredi
jeudi
4 5 mars et puis vendredi 6 mars à
montréal faisait bon bah je vais faire
je me suis réveillé et puis chez loblaw
et puis et puis je me suis filmé en
train de faire ses calculs vraiment à la
rage à ce moment-là tout j'avais
quasiment rien lu j'ai prié ses
discussions informelles et sinon
quelques lectures de l'om mais ces
quelques lectures enfin la vidéo de
tania lui et sinon le blog de l'être une
efficace et on sait ce essentiellement
cet oubli paya aussi je regardais pas
mal les chiffres sur wikipédia du coup
j'ai fait le calcul avec les estimations
et tout ça c'est un exercice de
magnifiques et très intéressant quand
nous vivons cette vidéo pour cet aspect
et et la question s'était posée c'est
est-ce que j'ai le corps en agressant
plus ça faisait un petit réceptacle
rythme et être très très très bien et je
me suis ainsi qu'en faisant ses calculs
ensuite en réalisant aussi un truc que
j'ai eue de fribourg en banque qui est
floue on en avait partagé la croissance
exponentielle c'est aussi ça m'a fait
pas mal intrigué c'est peut-être aussi
un déclic il me fait dire ouais il ya
quelque chose d'intéressant a pendu
mathématiques aussi à partager un truc
éducatif d'un point de vue mathématique
du coup on braque léger j'ai fait la
vidéo est dans la vidéo
et en fait je savais pas qu est ce que
j'ai ce que j'allais obtenir en faisant
un vidéo sert que c'est vraiment va je
lance les calculs et quelques jeux les
faits sont là et veut dans la vidéo
c'est quelqu'un que j'avais pas fait au
préalable
et quand je fais les calculs je me rends
compte que ça fait foi disent toutes les
deux semaines
d'après la courbe de fleury en born et
faut disent toutes les semaines toutes
les deux semaines
à la fin du mois ça faisait 10 % 10 % de
la population attraper le court aux
navires us à la fin du mois non c'était
simplement de service et parce qu'il
faut à dix c'était 10% pour moi et pour
aggraver comme j'avais estimé qu'ils
étaient cinq à dix fois plus exposés que
les autres
ça faisait en portion de la population
la fin du mois pour sa population la fin
du mois c'était une norme est
essentiellement au bout de deux mois
enfin ça sature quoi on attend enfin on
commence à avoir le l'immunité de groupe
du coup là on obtient en fonction des
prédictions des épidémiologistes
peut-être entre 40 et 70 % des gens
infectés
si on ne fait rien du coup on se passe
de deux mois est-ce qu on était préparés
farif eye-fi se prépare absolument à ce
moment là pour que dans deux mois soit
près c'était un petit peu le message
aussi de cette vidéo qui a été revu par
plein de gens en lui l'algorithme que
j'ai utilisée aussi optimisé pour
produire cette vidéo est aussi optimisée
sachant l'état de mes connaissances à ce
moment là avec un minimum d'effort de ma
part et de temps de travail de ma part
pour produire la vidéo le plus possible
d'y décéder je produis mon truc je me
montre à plein de gens qui me font des
retours et je rajoute point de remarques
à l'écran je pense que c'était une bonne
façon de procéder
j'ai beaucoup appris avec les remarques
des gens notamment mettre en avant
beaucoup plus le problème de l'urgence
des fonds de la surcharge des milieux
hospitaliers ça c'était très très
important en fait c'est un des messages
importants autour du cours d'un virus et
du coup j'ai vraiment beaucoup appris en
faisant cette vidéo de c'est très très
très content de cette vidéo en fait
c'était la meilleure façon pour moi sont
là sans doute de m'informer au sujet du
courroux navires us j'ai eu beaucoup de
retours qui a égalé dans beaucoup de
sens beaucoup de gens
ouais j'ai vraiment essayé de tirer un
peu juste milieu entre tous les retours
que j'ai eu un acquis qui régit des
retours de gens qui me disaient qu'il
fallait pas faire de projections sur une
étude vraiment pas bayésienne des gens
qui voulaient pas que je mette de
probabilité non plus une étude très
nombreux et viennent
et ça ça m'a beaucoup préoccupé parce
que si les gens n'ont pas une attitude
deux pays viennent dans ce genre de
situation c'est à dire que les gens vont
passer ceux projetés ils vont pas
imaginer une ensemble des cas possibles
dans le futur et en particulier ne va
pas préparer les cas les plus extrêmes
donc ça ça m'a beaucoup beaucoup
préoccupé après j'ai vu des gens qui
vous qui ont trouvé que la vidéo était
trop alarmiste il y avait des
estimations d'épidémiologistes ou
d'experts dans duke sécurité que j'ai vu
passer qui disait que ça doublerait
toutes les semaines ou tous les six
jours quelque chose comme ça donc ça
ferait x 5 x 4 x 5 au boulot enfin
toutes les deux semaines donc c'est
beaucoup moins que le rythme et quelques
cultures
j'ai utilisé deux fois dix toutes les
deux semaines dans la vidéo et safran a
énormément de choses ça parce que en
gros si ça faisait que x 2 enfin que ça
faisait que x 4 x 5 toutes les deux
semaines
on aurait encore quatre mois pour se
préparer trois quatre mois pour se
préparer et inverse j'ai vu passer des
trucs qui disait que ça ferait foi 3
toutes les
toutes les semaines dans non c'est
toutefois deux toutes et tous les trois
jours du coup x 25 toutes les deux
semaines et x 25 toutes les deux
semaines c'était enfin c'était c'était
vraiment effrayant 25,8 et de semaine
mais en même temps les années ce qui
faisait sa de ce que je voyais faisait
surtout une régression linéaire et c'est
ce que j'ai fait aussi dans la vidéo est
a priori j'avais l'impression que cette
méthode très machine learning on va dire
était
et étaient moins fiables que les
prédictions des épidémiologistes qui eux
ont des raisonnements ils incluent dans
leurs prédictions leur propre expertise
et du coup j'étais en fait en faisant ça
du tout j'étais presque gêné de dire un
nombre aussi grand qu'il faut à 10
toutes les deux semaines
j'ai hésité à mettre un bémol sur ça
mais en faisant la vidéo je me suis dit
bon quand même une ressource qui a l'air
de gens sérieux des piloris ce qu'il
faut à 25
beaucoup plus que ce que j'ai dit moi et
en même temps c'est pas plus mal de
pousser les gens vers les cas un peu
plus extrême du coup voilà j'ai essayé
ça comme ça avec le bémol que ça c'est
peut-être entre x 115 x 25
il se trouve que c'est on était sur un
rythme on est sur un rythme deux fois
cinquante voire poisson ouais ça double
tous les deux à trois jours pas tout à
tous les cas pas tous les six jours
c'est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus rapide que toutes
les prédictions les plus rapides que
j'avais vu passer à ce moment là et c
c'est la grosse faille de cette vidéo
mais c'est une faille tout à fait enfin
chevaux installe la bonne chose à
communiquer il me semble je me suis
vraiment fier aux avis des
épidémiologistes ça collait avec les
données basse et s'il y avait je pense
que c'était tout à fait raisonnable de
ma part d'avoir partagé ces chiffres
jusque j'ai mal fait par contre cesson
mesurer l'étendue de mon ignorance et ce
qui est difficile c'est plutôt je pense
avoir mal mesuré l'étendue de
l'ignorance finalement des experts
puisque là on sortait des marges
d'erreur assez nettement des marges
d'erreur proposées par les experts ce
cas les experts que j'avais vu
communiquer à ce sujet et ça ça me fait
dire qu'il faut absolument écouter les
experts ont beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
plus fiable que quelques autres du même
sur experts peut-être que en tout cas
sur ce coup il fallait rajouter mais
c'est facile de dire un poster mais
peut-être classement est fait rajouter
encore plus une marge d'erreur c'est
assez compliqué que toujours est il que
l'une des conséquences importantes de ce
que je dis là c'est que oui je pense que
le gouvernement français pour tous les
gouvernements au monde ont été pris de
quoi il y avait peut-être moins d'être
plus rapide que ce qu'ils ont été dans
qui peut si l'on était dans les mesures
de prévention du court aux navires us
mais
et peut-être qu'ils ont été mal informés
aussi mais même sachant tout cela on vit
comme dans un cas vraiment vraiment
vraiment extrêmes donc je vais envie de
dire que
il faut être un peu aussi tolérants en
tout cas moi j'aurais sont fait moins
bien encore en tout cas pas mieux que
les gens au pouvoir
enfin c'est vraiment compliqué et puis
il ya beaucoup d'enjeux il n'ya pas y'a
pas être juste sauver des vies les
enjeux économiques importants une
transition à faire vers le confinement
qui était important enfin je pense qu
elle qui a pas eu à cette préparation
mais je pense qu'il faut être assez
tolérant aussi faut vraiment juger le
pari est pas il pas le résultat parce
qu'on veut si on avait peur qu'il ya un
biais de résultats et qu'on se dit que
si la situation est vraiment
catastrophique et que du coup on blâme
très sévèrement des personnes je pense
qu'il ya lieu de blâmer sévèrement
certaines personnes parce que même si ça
avait fait un x 5 toutes les deux
semaines
on aurait sans doute été pris de court
qu'il y ait quand même lieu de n'être
des blagues mais attention à ne pas
mettre des blâmes à cause du biais de
résultats on vit vraiment dans un cas
plus extrêmes à l'appropriation été plus
rapide que tous les modèles que j'ai vu
passer jusque là et toutes les opinions
des experts que j'avais vu passer jusque
là voilà donc faire cette vidéo
finalement
que communiqués en cette vidéo ces
dilemmes éthiques
je pense que vont suis pas trop mal
sorti
dans cette vidéo en voyant la vidéo je
me dis que c'est peut vraiment pas si
mal tout ce que j'ai fait même si le cac
qui a vraiment lieu sortait des marges
d'erreur
peut-être qu'il fallait on peut plus
douter encore rajouté des marges
d'incertitude sur les avis des
différents modèles et des différents
experts
or dans la foulée
vendredi le vendredi 6 mars donc le
vendredi 6 mars lorsque j'ai tourné dans
la vidéo est sortie le vendre le lundi
qui suit velin 19 mars avec beaucoup
d'éditions tout au long du week-end
c'était un peu le rush et vendredi 6
mars et j'ai eu une autre décision
difficile à prendre qui a été décidé ou
non d'aller à paris donc je suis allé à
paris pour montrer différentes personnes
également donné une conférence entre sa
centrale supélec sur le sujet de
l'éthique des algorithmes en particulier
pour présenter enfin pour parler de mon
article scientifique eux préféré de 2019
que je reconduis oublier mots qui
s'appelle we built y est je pense qu'en
plus poster je peux dire que la
discussion que j'ai eue les discussions
que j'ai eues un centrale supélec avec
les étudiants notamment ont été
extrêmement
bénéfique et donc beaucoup beaucoup de
plus être allé à paris
est-ce que ça a été responsable de ma
part d'aller à paris par contre ça ça se
discute vraiment j'avais estimé à ce
moment là ma priorité d'avoir le corps
une arrivée lloris à 0,1 pour cent notre
réalité de l'attraper à paris sachant
que j'allais faire très très graves
comme étant à paris on peu près à 0 1%
également peut-être un peu plus pas
beaucoup plus je pense que ces calculs
sont globalement juste ce que j'ai mal
estimé ces probabilités enfin de
l'estimation de l'espérance du nombre de
personnes que je risque de contaminer en
allant à paris donc vu que j'allais
faire très très gaffe mais disait que de
toute façon le nombre de personnes que
j'avais contaminés même si j'ai le
coronavirus appel n'est pas être énormes
mais enfin j'ai quand-même interagit
avec beaucoup de gens donc il ya quand
même probablement j'aurais pu la voir
filer comme au moins une personne
extraits que c'est que si je le fil si
je contamine une personne supposant que
j'ai coronavirus en allant paris re et
que les interactions va peut-être en
moyenne je touche une personne ne
contamine une personne à cause du cours
d'un virus et si je fais ça le problème
c'est que cette personne peut ensuite de
commencer tout un tout une chaîne de
contamination et du coup cette personne
peut-être quelqu'un va contaminer elle
même trois personnes ces trois personnes
ont connu de contaminer chacune trois
personnes liens sino suite est en fait
que je n'ai pas fait ces essais et
prendre en compte toute cette chaîne et
cette croissance exponentielle qui qui
qui continue en particulier au bout de
dix sauts comme ça en fait on obtient 60
mille personnes contaminées si chacun qu
on a eu trois personnes du coup on fait
en allant à paris si j'ai le corps d'un
virus qui arrivait de probabilités un
sur mille 0,1 pour cent ici je
contaminent en moyenne une personne est
cette personne
créer une chaîne qui va ensuite
contaminer potentiellement des dizaines
de milliers de personnes et du coup en
espérance même si je multiplie cette
fois par la probité que j'ai le court
aux navires us il se trouve que ça fait
des dizaines peut être des centaines d'
infecté et du coup potentiellement un
mort du coup si j'avais fait le
raisonnement a priori je me serais dit
qu'en allant quand choisissons d'aller à
paris c'est comme si je tuais
indirectement quelqu'un en moyenne et si
j'avais fait au prix sar en contrebas
probablement la décision d'aller à paris
aurait été différente tout cas c'est un
calcul que je regrette vraiment de ne
pas avoir fait je pense que beaucoup de
bien que j'ai eues en allant à paris
peut-être que aussi l'estimation de
10/10 au comme ça que de la chaîne c'est
peut-être une succion c'est ça même sans
doute une surestimation mais à ce moment
là je savais pas que l'on se dirigeait
vers un confinement aussi rapidement en
france
et du coup l'idée qu'ils aient plusieurs
sauts comme ça était pas non plus si
farfelue bref je pense ne pas avoir bien
raisonné donc là c'est un point négatif
je sais pas si je serai à paris si
j'avais fait tout ce raisonnement mais
pour le coup j'ai mal raisonné à ce
moment là et donc un point négatif pour
les pour cette décision d'aller à paris
vendredi 6 mars
un sixième dilemme auquel j'ai
confrontés c'est lorsque j'ai reçu un
message je vais amener misé beaucoup de
choses mais de messages en gros de
quelqu'un qui connaît très bien
quelqu'un au gouvernement au fond proche
du gouvernement plus tôt et qui m'a
proposé du coup de relayer un message
c'est un message qui a été
qui est passée entendu ce qu'est un truc
à dire ces personnes là et la sq à un
gros dilemme de légitimité on donne de
ma part il ya un peu l'urgence de la
situation
mais est ce que je suis illégitime ce
que j'ai finalement un avis qui sera
finalement plus bénéfique entre entendu
que celui des spécialistes qui et les
experts qui conseillent déjà ces
personnes proches du gouvernement
nous les grosses difficultés de sas et
je sais pas qui sont ces experts au
gouvernement je sais pas comment ces
experts au gouvernement conseille les
personnes du gouvernement et
du coup je sais pas s'ils n'ont plus à
quel point le gouvernement écoute ces
personnes là quel point sont enclines à
davantage écouter quelqu'un comme moi
qui ne connaissent pas ça paraissait
assez compliqué et à ce moment là
j'étais vraiment attention c'est
vraiment un problème difficile parce que
le matin même
j'avais reçu l'appel d'un ami
mathématicien assez paniqué parce que
ils savaient que il avait entendu dire
que les hôpitaux et des agences
sanitaires et les les médecins à ce
moment là considéré encore que le
coronavirus a été plus fin moins grave
que la grippe et surtout on m'a dit que
beaucoup rejeter la simple idée de faire
des projections dans le futur on parle
on parle notamment de courbe
exponentielle en conciliant qu'il
s'agissait de futurologie rejetant sa
comme la futurologie et que du coup ça
aucune devait rédiger et c'est un
message qui est beaucoup entendu aussi
éviter la spéculation et tout ça par
ailleurs j'avais entendu dire à ce
moment là que j'avais compris plutôt que
le président de l'opl avait décidé de
rendre enfin de mettre tous les cours en
ligne malgré l'avis contraire de d
les agences sanitaires en suisse qui
apparemment était beaucoup moins
alarmiste et qui du coup pensais que
c'était des rovers actionne une sur
réaction
et du coup à ce moment là j'ai commencé
à avoir vraiment une tension entre qui
sont ces experts quelles sont leurs
modèles
est-ce qu'ils sont balisés en est ce
qu'ils font des projections vers
l'avenir est-ce qu'ils comprennent les
dangers d'une courbe exponentielle
peut-être que du coup ça valait le coup
de communiqués mais en même temps est-ce
que j'étais vraiment légitime
ce que j'aurai chose à super hype
idéologues je ne suis que mathématicien
je pense avoir des compétences qui sont
déficientes dans plein d'autres domaines
mais dans ce cas précis
est ce que c'est vraiment une expertise
qui est qui et qui compte vraiment voilà
j'ai toujours est il que j'ai décidé de
ne pas relayer des messages de ne pas
demander en tout cas calmer sa riche
histoire relayer ou autre que ma vidéo
et 8,8 a posteriori on peut vraiment se
demander si c'était une bonne décision
de me pas assez c'est assez compliqué
mois il se trouve que peu près au même
moment
quand je le savais pas encore à ce
moment là mais à peu près au même moment
le ms tire la sonnette d'alarmé car il
parle de pandémie selon un message
extrêmement fins très alarmiste donc si
je savais ça j'aurais juste recommandé
d'écouté l'om est finalement mais avant
de voir ça s'il y avait une énorme
tension au fond de moi bon finalement
j'ai décliné
est-ce que c'était la bonne décision
avec le recul c'est compliqué parce que
peut-être que si j'avais réagi à ce
moment là si j'avais été plus alarmiste
ça c'est ça paraît très improbable d'une
façon mais peut-être que ça augmente
sera augmentée par exemple la priorité
qui est que les municipales soient
annulées et
un peu peut-être qu'il y aurait une
conséquence j'ai aussi réagi très vite
j'ai pas consulté d'autres personnes qui
aura peut-être fallu que je consulte
également c'était compliqué je pense
avoir pas fait de mon mieux dans ce cas
mais que c'était vraiment très compliqué
je ne sais pas ce que vous pensez que
j'aurais dû faire dès lors pour chaque
dilemme je vous invite écrire dit l'un
d'eux votre avis sur ce que j'aurais dû
faire une autre difficulté que j'ai eue
à ce moment là c'est aussi savoir
quelles épidémiologistes recommandé qui
recommandait en fait même moi
personnellement je savais pas à qui
faire confiance et je faisais
essentiellement confiance
le ms ad ami en qui j'ai confiance
ipdia des sources renvoyé
par wikipedia est en gros à mes calculs
paysans que
le 7ème 10ème que j'ai eu c'est
le jeudi matin je me suis dit oh faut
que j'assure la fonte de suite jusque là
j'étais encore voilà je lui apporte un
peu menés expertise mais voilà je suis
pas la personne légitime jeudi matin et
je suis pas et je pense mercredi un peu
un basculement et j'ai peut-être eu
besoin de la nuit pour y réfléchir
mais voilà une jolie je me suis mis en
mode full faut que j'agisse assez
j'oublie tout
toutes mes autres priorités le corps à
nice c'est ma priorité maintenant c'est
déjà commencé un peu mercredi
ouais j'ai envoyé de buzz email à des
gens en redemandent en voilà j'aimerai
interview un gêne épidémiologistes
notamment qui recommandaient les jeux
dangereux
c'était très compliqué on a vu plusieurs
noms passés à ces gens que je connais
pas c'est toujours un peu compliqué si
on s'en doute surchargé et du coup si je
vais peut-être passer d'abord par le
café des sciences danser des
épidémiologistes au café des sciences
même ça je ne savais pas vraiment à ce
moment là enfin je savais un petit peu
parce que pour la vidéo et j'allais
changer un peu avec thibaut fiolet mais
pas plus que ça et lui en thèse
peut-être que s'il y avait un professeur
établi sur le sort était mieux
du coup j'en vois un email au café des
sciences en disant il faut il faut agir
par chance je n'étais pas le seul à
penser ça donc été plusieurs fois j'ai
vu passer plusieurs tweets mais c'est
aussi compliqué parce que on va les gens
ce que j'ai ensuite ce qu'ils pensent
vraiment voilà c'était compliqué aussi
de jauger l'état d'esprit global
notamment du café des sciences
mais bref je suis envoyé un e-mail au
café des sciences président lui ça
serait vraiment bien que qu'on agisse
je lis mais elle est là mais je veux que
la mairie fasse un truc je serais
vraiment fier si on fait vraiment
quelque chose c'est pousser les gens à
agir mais mes deux propositions étaient
assez légères en finançant une
communication officielle du café des
sciences pour impacter finalement c'est
l'unité qui a fait ici on s'est beaucoup
moins de bus que que que les crocs
chaîne youtube de vulgarisation
scientifique
il pense et horticoles vie 171 tout ça
et puis la deuxième proposition c'était
juste interviewé un épidémiologiste si
on avait un au caire et sciences donc
finalement joseph s il aura fallu 8 ans
et thibault que j'ai interviewés mais
bon beaucoup plus tard parce que
finalement c'était pas urgent à ce
moment là je pense qu'à ce moment là
c'était urgent d'avoir un message simple
et clair et c'est bien on nous vend du
café exactement qui avait proposé le
premier l'idée d'une vidéo collaborative
en tout cas stéphane thebaut puis me
suffit thibault a beaucoup sauté c'est
sur cette idée ont vraiment insisté sur
ça et ça c'était jeudi matin tout pas
mal de discussions énormément de
d'e-mails envoyés au café c'était cool
de voir cette mobilisation
mais là il fallait que quelqu'un prenne
les choses en main en fallait faire et
que ça aille vite à chaque jour comptait
y avait vraiment été une course contre
la montre à ce moment là déjà le cas
dans ma tête donc là j'ai commencé à
écrire inscrits à faire un programme
avec des belles années tous à mettre en
place quelques règles pour pouvoir y
arriver
et ensuite j'ai envoyer cette email au
café en disant on y va même si à ce
moment là
c'était hésitez encore est-ce que
c'était une vidéo non du café ou non il
est plein de choses a décidé voilà
j'avais j'étais vraiment dans le temps
l'urgence à ce moment je voulais une
action rapide et d'habitude deux soirs
de prises de décisions d'une association
faut que ça passe par le bureau et tout
ça moi j'étais prêt à griller les étapes
et s'il le fallait parce que je pense
qu'ils avaient vraiment vraiment
l'urgence mais bien sûr il y avait
encore plein de débat et est tout à fait
des sciences ce n'était pas dans le même
état d'esprit que moi thibault où
c'était faire une france que fan ou
trois l'ont été à peu près sur le même
la même longueur d'onde et autres
peut-être un peu différent en
particulier il ya eu des débats sur le
fait d'intervenir dans ce problème de
santé publique à grande échelle avec des
recommandations qui a priori sort pas
mal de la communication scientifique en
tout cas est telle qu'on va faire et
d'habitudes faire une vidéo déjà avec
une deadline ça c'est un truc c'est en
deux jours c'est un truc qu'on fait
qu'on fait jamais dans un café des
sciences ou très très très rarement on
va dire ou pas ces sites est très
différente de d'habitude
et puis aussi à la question de la
légitimité finalement au café des
sciences bahia thibault fiolet et sinon
il n'y avait pas vraiment des experts en
épidémiologie et du coup il y avait
d'énormes problèmes de légitimité
beaucoup utilisé faut donner la parole
aux épidémiologistes méfiant il n'y a
pas beaucoup au café des sciences et
finalement est ce que c'est vraiment à
ces personnes là qu'il faut demander de
communiquer sur ce sujet ce qui vont
être suffisamment bon communicateur
s'efface était vraiment c'est vraiment
des questions compliquées et je pense
qu'il faut faut éviter d'avoir des
réseaux d'eau trop simpliste à ces
sujets parce que c'est vraiment vraiment
compliqué en situation de crise ce qui
se font être disponible aussi s'immiscer
une des grandes questions importantes
là il ya plein plein de choses qui font
que c'était une situation dont la
situation de crise et c'était compliqué
et il y avait des avis divergents et
chacun avait des arguments valides mais
là il nous faut juger
différents arguments et prendre une
décision et c'était vraiment pas facile
je pense qu'avec des débats un peu sous
jacent sur le degré d'urgence de la
situation
parce que thibault c'était fade moi et
d'autres
emilie pascal va d'autres on était
extrêmement dans l'urgence on parlait
beaucoup de exponentielle typiquement et
chaque jour compte et tout ça alors que
d'autres étaient beaucoup plus sur la
fiabilité de degré de crédibilité et
tout ça donc c'était il ya pas mal de
tension et en particulier un peu un
article qui caractérise beaucoup c'est
qui ces sept
cette tension qui est l'article 2 de
tomates bio dont vous avez sans doute
entendu parler qui eric et un article
qui n'est pas écrit par un
épidémiologiste qui n'est pas un article
pire au vieux doit cesser très loin des
c'est pas du tout le standard
des sciences mais en même temps c'est un
article qui parle de données qui fait de
l'analyse de données qui fait de
l'extrapolation qui a une analyse qui
est ce qu'elle est mais c'est une
analyse intéressante et surtout qu'il
n'avait pas à y est enfin cette année
elle faisait cette analyse et la
partager publiquement ce que j'avais pas
vu d'autres gens de faire qu'elle le
faisait façon beaucoup plus visible en
tout cas c'est l'article que tout le
monde voyait et qui avait alerté
beaucoup de gens du du café visiblement
du coup il ya eu un énorme le débat sur
est-ce qu'on en parle qu'on ne parle pas
bon je pense assez rapidement on s'est
dit on n'en parle pas mais surtout après
ce qu'on le cite dans la france non et
finalement on l'a pas mis dans les
références n'ont mangé j'ai tranché un
peu ce débat il fait non non ne met pas
je pense que ça ça rajoute est pas tant
que ça et ça faisait beaucoup de débats
au sein du café beaucoup de tensions
mais je pense que c'est nice est une
question un peu plus globale que c'est
ce genre d'article qui font de l'analyse
de données qui tire des des
extrapolations qui appellent à l'action
et moi personnellement je trouve que
l'article fait une analyse venait tout à
fait intéressante et qui méritent d'être
partagées et beaucoup plus en tout cas
que beaucoup d'autres choses qui avait
été partagée à ce moment-là il voyait
pas d'autre chose a recommandé aussi
c'était assez compliqué alors que par
exemple aurait mais c'est tout ça enfin
surtout les gouvernements les sites
gouvernementaux
c'est beaucoup
on dire en rétrospective c'est pas
tellement dans la projection et avant ça
parle assez peu de courbe exponentielle
finalement et du cou l'article de thomas
ce trio vous ferai quelque chose un
complément d'analysé que n'offrait pas
les les sources officielles
du coup enfin il y avait un intérêt
français a recommandé un peu cet article
mais il y avait aussi tout les bémols à
m d'ailleurs ce dernier l'avait partagé
en demi teinte
je me suis un peu la réaction
intéressante à voir au caire il ya une
réaction intéressante avoir vis-à-vis de
cet article et qui a enfin depuis ça
c'est un peu le bordel avec cet article
beaucoup de gens on parle de pseudo
science que ça m'a beaucoup trop fort
pour pour parler d'une analyse de
données que quand je fais une régression
linéaire sur l'ordinateur j'appelle
presse adapté aux sciences mais en même
temps c'est qu'avant pas une source
aussi fiable que des analyses
d'épidémiologistes je pense qu'il faudra
meilleur langage pour parler de ces
articles et je pense que surtout en fait
tousser a révélé une tension un peu plus
fondamentale au sein du café des
sciences entre de philosophie morale
plus conséquentialiste où beaucoup
étaient plus préoccupés par sauver des
vies avoir évité une catastrophe
économique parce qu'on s'était pas
préparé et qu'on tombe se contaminer
mutuellement les hôpitaux surchargés les
des entreprises où il ya plus de gens
qui vont travailler tout à coup sans
préparation et du coup des effondrements
cours de bourse mais voilà il y avait
des scénarios vraiment point du
conséquentialiste il fallait vraiment
vraiment vraiment réagi leur fréquence
est peut-être une approche plus
déontologique qui disait à chacun son
job
chacun ses responsabilités c'est pas
notre responsabilité de communiquer
c'est pas on a chacun sa légitimité aux
yeux on n'est pas légitime pour parler
de ça je pense qu'il ya vraiment cette
tension entre conséquent séisme et
déontologie et l'or c'est vrai qu'à
ultra appliquée ultra pratique
je pense que c'est très intéressant de
voir que ces réflexions qui parfois ont
l'air un peu de théorie de la
philosophie morale
en fait là c'était vraiment le cas ultra
pratique avec littéralement des milliers
de vies en jeu
donc c'était assez chaud
je pense que assez bien géré la
situation
content du résultat mais je pense que la
tension et du résultat et puis surtout
on peut toujours se demander est ce
qu'on aura pu faire mieux dans les
messages qu'on a envoyé est ce qu'on
aura été n'aurait pu être plus clair
plus court plus concis plus
bienveillants plus plus confiance et
enfin c'est très très compliqué et là on
est en mode rachel de bâton mieux était
ultra ultra important
alors ça c'était jeudi
pendant 1 journée de jeudi tout ça ça
déborde un peu sur londres dit bien sûr
mais le jeudi soir du coup il ya eu le
discours de mâcon qui commençait déjà
les mesures de dissension sociale mais
qui maintenait les municipales bon voilà
ça c'est un peu alice young mc on pourra
critiquer plus tard c'est pas l'objet
ici je cherche plus à me critiquer moi
et mes prises de décision et en
particulier à ce moment là il y avait
une question qui se pose est celle que
moi les mesures ont été prises par mâcon
est ce que la vidéo ça vaut encore le
coup de la faire inscrire encore urgence
à la faire parce que il faut la
précipiter tels que tel qu on le fait et
donc certains ont remis en cause sa
ferme vidéo collaborative aussi comme ça
ça comporte des risques
on met en avant des gens
enfin s'associe à des gens en lesquels
on n'a pas forcément toujours envie de
s'associer peut avoir des tensions comme
ça où des désaccords tels que certaines
personnes n'ont pas aimé la f1 c'est
vraiment des discussions qui ont lieu
d'aider j'en étais pas chaud pour
participer à cette vidéo parce qu'ils
avaient peur que dans les vidéos
créatives comme ça y ait des gens qui
participent et et qu'on soit du coût
associé à ces personnes là et que du
coup à chaque fois qu'on critique cette
autre personne là bas les gens associent
inconsciemment ou non nous à cette
personne n'a du coup on est aussi
indirectement critiqué même si on
partage pas l'avis des personnes âgées
c'est compliqué tout ça et il ya des
gens qui n'ont pas participé à cause de
cet argument donc ces derniers ont tout
à fait y avait des arguments tout à fait
valide pour ne pas participer à cette
valide cette vidéo est l'un des
nouvelles du nouvel argument du bon
argument c'était le fait que suite au
discours de mâcon peut être qu'à vidéo
aura beaucoup moins d'impact que ce
qu'elle aurait eu 100 le discours de
mâcon peut-être que ça refroidit
incertain et tu vois moi ça va refroidir
en simplement terme en la vidéo aurait
moins eu moins d'impact mais j'ai eu du
coup je sais c'est un instant
d'hésitation c est ce qu on y va encore
vous ce qu'on n'y va pas et moi je vais
chercher aussi à convaincre de personnes
d'y aller qu'ils utilisaient bon ben moi
j'y vais pas à cause de ça et du coup
c'est là que je pense là je mets un
point positif pour le lait à ce moment
là c'est s'est dit il faut quantifier ça
c'est dans le monde c'est bien beau
d'avoir des discours comme ça seul bien
d'avoir un ordre de grandeur et du coup
j'ai conservé griffonné
dès l'été calcul j'ai fait sur excel et
ils sont disponibles vous pouvez aller
les voir et du coup j'ai envié ça
du coup à une personne que j'ai cherché
à convaincre parce si l'animal je pas si
tu es la personne en question
mais le petit modèle que je propose bas
il ya des paramètres qui sont inconnus
et qu'il faut estimer et le truc c'est
que le résultat final est très dépendant
des paramètres qu'on utilise alors ça je
rajoute bien sûr dans toutes les
discussions
mettez vos propres paramètres ce soit
les concernant certaines de tout ça mais
finalement il ya qu un seul fichier
excel a envoyé peut-être que j'aurais pu
en envoyer plusieurs copies va plusieurs
simulations comme ça mais notre cas il y
en avait une en première à montrer et du
coup la question que s'est posée c'est
qu'elle va leur jeu mais un par exemple
dans le modèle l'idée c'est que moi
suite au discours de mâcon une certaine
propre poids pour voir sur la population
et qui va être prudente
gb 50% la population responsable est ce
que c'était vraiment 50% des populations
pourquoi est ce que j'ai mis 50 % assez
pense que si j'avais réfléchi davantage
mais aussi si je pense que la part de la
proportion que présidente de la
population suite au discours de
maquereau est plus faible que 50 %
peut-être de l'ordre de près de 30% il
ya beaucoup de gens qui vont pas sont
pas entendus qui m'ont pas écouté le
discours de mâcon qui m'ont pas fait
gaffe parce que beaucoup de personnes
qui n'aiment pas mâcon et qui du coup
nous devons juste réagir en disant il
raconte des bêtises et du coup vous pas
prêté attention au discours de mâcon et
puis il ya juste des gens qui sont qui
était déjà à la base très sceptiques du
coronavirus et du coup ils restent très
sceptiques malgré un discours de mâcon
comment choisir ce chiffre voilà je
pense vraiment que c'est un peu moins
mais j'avais quand même il 50% et voit
le plot 10ème se posait sur chacun des
paramètres pendant qu'il y avait un
autre paramètre c'était parmi nos viewer
quelle est la proportion des personnes
qui va être qu'ils sont déjà prudentes
et puis parmi ces gens là qu'est la
proportion des gens qu'on va réussir à
convaincre
on va tout plein de paramètres comme ça
à chaque fois il faut mettre un chiffre
quelque pression quantifie tout ça et le
résultat dépend beaucoup du chiffre du
oui à la question se pose est-ce et
quels chiffres je met dedans quels
nombre d'infectés aussi un stand prison
sachant que rial nombre de cas confirmés
du coup ce qui est plus intéressant pour
les simulations c'est combien il ya de
cas réels jean vie dure et du coup à ce
moment là j'ai choisi des chiffres qui
ce qui était assez conservateur ac qui
défendent est pas tellement mon opinion
notamment parce que d'une part il pointe
de l'honnêteté intellectuelle mais aussi
le problème de pour convaincre les gens
parfois dire ce qu'on pense directement
bas valais rebuter sais j'ai vu ça sur
certains trucs
comment sur le fait de faire des stocks
petit à petit et de s'isoler chez soi
très tôt dans l'épidémie j'avais vu ses
conseils je les avais relayée en privé à
certaines personnes et certaines
personnes ont été les arômes utilisés en
baie du coup c'est n'importe quoi
et du coup ce soir était peut-être mieux
d'avoir une approche plus progressive
je me suis fait le même raisonnement
dans ce débat si je vais pas mettre les
chiffres que je crois moi je vais
essayer de mettre les chiffres que la
personne à qui j'envoie ce fichier excel
croix j'essaie de me mettre ses
croyances dans le fichier excel et
peut-être que j'ai fait un excès de zèle
du coupé j'ai mis des chiffres plus bas
qu'à si je revois l'estimation en fait
c'est beaucoup plus fort beaucoup plus
et plus en tout cas que que je pense
avoir été optimiste pour la maladie du
coup pas assez dans l'urgence à ce
moment là dans ce fichier excel mais il
ya un point positif pour les d'avoir
pensé à faire ce fichier excel d'avoir
développé le modèle tout ça en temps
réel en l'espace de quelques minutes
et cette situation de crise qu est un
point négatif pour les parce que je
pense qu'il ya eu un excès de zèle sur
ce fichier excel et j'aurais peut-être
dû mettre un truc un peu plus proche de
ce que je croyais vraiment est un peu
plus honnête dans un officier
franchement je pense qu'avoir c'est
facile de dire après coup c'est facile
de dire après coup mais bon quoi ouais
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez vous
ensuite
après midi
gasly matin l'après midi du vendredi 13
mars a eu un débat sur la date de
publication du du de la vidéo collective
avec d'autres vulgarisateurs
scientifiques notamment dans le bureau
du café des sciences recommandait de
d'augmenter les délais de publication et
à un ou deux jours et moi j'étais très
content ressort je suis pas d'accord
mais je vais annoncer que j'allais être
dictateur sur la production de la vidéo
mais
l'asca allait à l'encontre du tube du
bureau du café les sciences avec une
association responsable du coup ma
réaction c'était de proposer un vote à
la place de ça est déjà dans le vote
j'ai pas été très réglo dire j'ai
proposé juste deux alternatives en gros
bas samedi soir ou
ou dimanche soir proposer ce vote au
café des sciences et très vite
enfin c'est on partait vraiment 50 50
voire légèrement plus pour augmenter le
délai du coup
très vite j'ai j'étais très très mal si
sa sauce maintenant il ya vraiment
vraiment urgence et du coup je me suis
lancé tout de suite dans des calculs en
disant mais quel est le nombre de vies
sauvées
donc j'ai fait un calcul à la rage je
crois que vous n'avez pas partagé au
café des sciences parce que c'était
vraiment à l'arraché c'était je sais
qu'il y ait des gens au café des
sciences qui n'aime pas ce genre de
calcul parce que ça ne fait pas très
scientifique mais je pense que c'est des
calculs mieux classés en ce moment là si
les débats sur casque la science et tous
avaient normalement avoir des
estimations comme ça bayésienne ça peut
être beaucoup plus fiables et en temps
de crise est beaucoup plus utile que
vous avez pas faire un test randomisés
contrôlés en double aveugle en temps de
crise de façon et donc le vote par
mallet du coup je rajoute des arguments
d'autres gens débattent tout ça donc
c'était un peu un vote que j'ai proposé
que j'ai tout de suite cherché à
influencer autant que possible by les
plaintes des débats intéressants des
arguments très intéressant et c'est
surtout sur la courbe exponentielle et
je pense vraiment que beaucoup de gens
au café des sciences sous-estiment les
courbes exponentielle et je pense même
que beaucoup de mathématiciens
sous-estiment vivement la croissance
exponentielle du cas moi chez
sous-estimé beaucoup la croissance
exponentielle on l'a vu notamment avec
le le troisième dilemme je crois que
c'était où j'ai décidé d'aller à paris
alors que savez quoi potentiellement
causer une chaîne de contamination à
croissance exponentielle de
l'accroissement exponentiel c'est très
très très très très très compétitif
j'insisterai j'avais assez dessus c'est
ultra ultra ultra contre intuitif et du
coup si vous faites un avis et vous
n'avez jamais réfléchi à une croissance
exponentielle
et comme on est en situation où ils
risquent de croissance exponentielle
j'ai envie de dire vous êtes interne à
vis mal informés et vous risquez de
prendre une décision qui ne prend pas en
compte les effets de la courbe
exponentielle
bref finalement
on dira tout finit bien le vote du
samedi soir gagne il ya un autre
raisonnement que me suis fait c'est à ce
moment là aussi du coup c'est un
raisonnement tu fais beaucoup trop tard
en tant que j'aurais dû faire dès le
début c'est que en fait il ya vraiment
urgence et du coup quand le public joue
beaucoup et en particulier samedi 18
heures ça peut faire une grosse
différence puisque ça peut encourager
des gens à ne pas sortir le samedi soir
et du coup ça rajoute et à l'urgence
c'est un truc qui n'est pas même pas
dans mes petits modèles et qui en fait
un facteur important
toute cette réflexion à larache c'était
très compliqué donc finalement le vote a
gagné dans mon sens on va dire du coup
j'ai envie de dire tout finit bien a
posteriori selon ce que je pense mais il
ya vraiment une question reste posée
pour le coup c est ce que j'aurais
vraiment dû proposer ça en vote
si le vote avait perdu j'aurais vraiment
vraiment très très épris j'aurai 20
jours est très très vraiment regretté
moi ma décision parce que je pense que
des vies auraient étaient mortes à cause
de ma décision d'y aller avec une
décision démocratique plutôt que
dictatorial à ce moment là je mets un
point négatif
allez pour avoir choisi d'y aller avec
le vote au moment où j'ai proposé le
vote je pense que je m'en rendais pas
compte de l'impact de l'exposant ciel et
du délai de publication et du fait que
samedi soir ça jouer beaucoup
point négatif pour les
c'est un point négatif est assez étrange
sans doute pour beaucoup d'entre vous
peut me dire ce que vous en pensez dans
les commentaires
quelle voix point négatif pour les
ensuite ce tour ce vendredi 13 mars je
me rends compte mais beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup trop tard que la situation va
être beaucoup plus horrible aux états
unis et au royaume uni et que le gros
temps le gros enjeu en fait c'est pas
une vidéo francophone
c'est une vidéo anglophone et là l'enjeu
l'enjeu est énorme et donc là vendredi
régis là pour le coup j'ai vraiment
honte d'avoir mis autant de temps avant
d'y penser c'est un truc qui aurait dû
sortir dès mercredi voir mardi
est-ce que très vite on se rend compte
qu aux etats-unis n'ont pas de test
fonction très en retard sur sur tout ce
qui est est qu' il va avoir un qui va
exploser aux etats-unis et déjà les
états unis pour la france aussi vous le
dire mais les états unis sont
particulièrement en tension politique
déjà à priori le débat autour du cou
rana virus tourne encore un peu plus au
débat démocratique et républicain ouais
il ya beaucoup de raisons de penser pour
que les etats unis se passe très très
mal j'avais appris j'ai appris le
vendredi
13 mars qu'il ya beaucoup de une pénurie
de vente fin de d'armes parce que les
gens se sont jetés sur l'achat d'armes
c'est beaucoup de raisons on va avoir
très peur du coup là j'ai envoyé un
e-mail à révéler des messages à des gens
des youtube aux anglophones scientifique
que je connais donc la part dont
celui-là à looking glass universe
donc je me suis à lui classé d'urgence
parce que du coup elle a fait une vidéo
il y en a trop qui malheureusement mis
plus de temps à faire la vidéo on pas
fait de vidéo l'enjeu est vraiment
énorme là on parle de crise en termes de
vies ont cessé une très rapidement sa
des centaines de milliers de vies par
pour chaque jour dix mille actions et
notamment une vidéo d'un très grand
youtuber peut-être des dizaines de
milliers de vies sauvées français c'est
vraiment les échelles sont vraiment
vraiment énorme en terme de vies mais
aussi en termes économiques
parce que un effondrement des états unis
mais ça serait catastrophique d'un point
de vue mondial enfin dépend énormément
des états unis pour énormément de choses
aussi les états unis tonfa ce serait une
crise économique majeure mondial ça veut
dire beaucoup de gens au chômage moi ya
beaucoup de discussions du coup pour
avoir un simili revenu universel pop
pour passer au moins la crise voire
peut-être un truc qui peut durer
enfin ça peut être très très très très
horrible qu'elle est beaucoup beaucoup
d'incertitudes sur ce qui peut arriver
et ça peut aller en guerre civile guerre
guerre mondiale france à lille il ya des
risques moi ça c'est qu'a vraiment
vraiment extrême mais c'était bien
risquer y est je pense qu'un truc comme
on vraiment le court d'ailleurs ce qu'il
faut vraiment réfléchir à ces cas
extrêmes on parle de ses victimes hans
est parfois de penser à la sécurité
qu'on ne pensait pas juste ou train
train quotidien as qu'il a le plus qui
est le plus probable mais penser au pire
cas et là je pense qu'il ya des risques
de pires cas qui sont vraiment vraiment
horrible et du coup ça serait vraiment
bien de mettre tous ont eu tous faire
tout ce qu'on peut pour les éviter et du
coup là à ce moment là
vidéo de youtube anglophone c'était très
très important gg content d'avoir pensé
seulement à ce moment là et j'ai essayé
de beaucoup poussé j'ai envie beaucoup
d'imagés beaucoup échangé avec beaucoup
de très gros youtuber anglophone
malheureusement ils n'ont pas été aussi
réactif que
le café des sciences avec la vidéo qu'on
connaît sortie nous ayant un petit peu
un petit délai dans les emails que j'ai
envoyé un des trucs que je regarde c'est
de ne pas avoir mis dès le premier email
des estimations quantifier du nombre de
vies que ça pourrait sauver c'est le
temps des emails suivants parce que
parce que il a fallu le temps pour moi
aussi de trouver ces arguments et tout
ça c'est parce que j'ai pas réfléchi pas
assez vite passé tôt je ne suis pas
préparé en fait elle a suffisamment
et voilà donc je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
parmi vous qui ont peut-être pensé qu'il
savait avant avant d'autres bien savoir
c'est une chose mais bien communiquer
acheter avec des bâtons mieux trouver
les meilleurs arguments et mettre plus
en avant possible peut devenir un peu
convaincante possible là c'était urgent
c'est pas juste savoir c'est aussi bien
communiquer bien convaincre et là
malheureusement j'ai été très très très
en retard un gros gros point négatif
pour pour les à ce moment là c'est il
aura fallu beaucoup mieux faire
enfin le dernier dit
éthique que j'ai eu et l'appareil si ça
arrive beaucoup trop tard et c'est con
parce que mehdi
une coauteure de mon livre m'avait déjà
fait la remarque genre autour du 5 mars
comme ça la semaine du 12 mars
il ya longtemps que j'ai mis 9 jours
avant de réagir moi c'est catastrophique
mais voilà je connais des gens qui
travaillent are you tube j'ai les amis
qui est qui qui travaillent à youtube et
j'ai aussi des contacts parce que je
suis youtuber de gens à youtube et donc
c'est seulement le samedi 14 mars que je
me suis mis à les supplier de changer
algoet une recommandation de youtube
pour mettre beaucoup plus en avant les
vidéos sur le court d'un virus et faire
beaucoup plus gaffe à tout ça aurier il
ya un énorme problème c'est que même à
ce moment là je ne savais pas quelle
vidéo recommandé parce que vous ayez des
vidéos sur le site de l'om est sur la
page du tube de ms mais voilà les vidéos
du vol réorganisation cdd confiance et
passait pas très youtube prentice et
c'est ce soit c'est un format assez
rigide c'est pas la meilleure
communication qu'il y a par chance il y
avait deux vidéos de la cie d'ici qui
sont sorties qui sont vraiment vraiment
vraiment top
si les centers for disease control aux
etats-unis lui-même cette vidéo à son
arrivée assez tardivement un date
du vendredi 13 mars et je ne connaissais
pas le samedi 14 mars
je n'hésite pas recommandée mais si
c'était un gros problème s'il manquait
de vidéos de qualité qui parle bien du
caue d'un virus et qui vont qui sont par
exemple à ces cours qui vont droit au
but qui explique vraiment les raisons de
faire les bonnes fondations en
particulier distanciation de social et
qui explique vraiment l'intérêt de
ladite station distanciation sociale est
ce que je veux dire ce qu'il faut faire
ça suffit pas ça augmente beaucoup il
capacité des gens enfin le fait que les
gens vont adopter ces méthodes de
distanciation social s'ils comprennent
quel est leur intérêt et du coup il
manquait énormément de contenus dans
cette direction pendant longtemps et en
fait c'est même pire que ça c'est que ce
n'est que le lundi 16 mars donc très
très très tard finalement que je me
rends compte que youtube en fait ne
recommande pas le dit aussi au cours
d'un virus qu'on sait ouvrir une
navigation privée à voir quels étaient
vides ou recommandés et le chrono virus
n'était pas aux commandes et et ça c'est
dramatique sur afficher pas ce que ça
veut dire que des gens qui ont vaguement
entendu parler du coroner virus qui
pensent que c'est un truc très longtemps
ils vont sur youtube et ça les conforte
dans cet état d'esprit puisque c'est
même pas un truc dont les gens parlent
sur youtube et du coup ça freine
énormément
la mise en place l'adoption des mesures
de prévention sociale de distanciation
social par la population et du couffin
c'est pourquoi c'est vraiment vraiment
cathos sont catastrophiques et c'est un
truc que j'aurais dû vérifier
enfin c'est son domaine d'expertisé que
je redis c'est le truc que j'ai fait il
ya ya ya ya deux mois ou un mois ou deux
pour voir ce que youtube ou d'autres
recommandent lorsqu'on cherche présent
klimato hockey est ce que le chien qu un
ticket est un fake intox
j'ai tendance à aimer regarder ce que
recommande youtube et je l'ait pas fait
pour le cas du du cornât virus enfin je
les fais selon beaucoup beaucoup trop
tard en gros deux semaines après que
mehdi me disent il faut que tu contexte
les gens à youtube peut donc la da pour
le coup j'ai vraiment vraiment content
de moi je pense que j'ai été assez moi
c'est un énorme point négatif de ma
gestion de crise
j'ai peut-être ma plus grande déception
dans toute cette histoire c'est de ne
pas avoir pensé plus tôt
rôle que joueront les algorithmes pour
la gestion de crise du corona virus
alors que sais-je écrire un bouquin de
succès c'est vraiment pour le coup ça
c'est un peu de ma part
voilà ça conclut cette longue vidéo
à chaque date ont bien sûr les dilemmes
éthiques autour du court en un virus
j'espère que vous ai montré que la
plupart des dilemmes éthiques sur le
coroner virus sont des problèmes
finalement de réclames du bâton mieux et
de belles et à nice mme et ses demandes
d'informations d'algorithmes de
recommandations qu'ils soient des
algorithmes appliqués par des machines
ou par des cerveaux humains vraiment en
fait une allemand cette crise allait au
coeur finalement j'ai l'impression de
sujets d'expertisé et sujet que que
j'adore c'est vraiment dommage que je
sois rendu compte aussi tu as et que
j'ai pris autant de mauvaises décisions
tout du long cheveu
je suis vraiment vraiment désolé j'ai
vraiment l'impression que que j'ai merdé
que j'ai vraiment vraiment vraiment
merdé c'était vraiment pas facile pour
pour excuser le lait du passé
c'était vraiment vraiment pas facile et
c'est loin d'être fini aussi on est
vraiment je pense encore au début de
cette crise
on espère bien sûr que ça va bien se
passer que dans les semaines à venir on
va pouvoir reprendre une vie plus
normale
mais il ya encore énormément énormément
d'incertitudes vous invite vraiment à
raisonner avec ses incertitudes
en particulier si vous commencez à avoir
des symptômes probablement vous pourrez
pas être testé
parce qu'il juste il ya pas assez de
deux outils de dépistage et du coup on
est pris aux risques pour des gens qui
ont vraiment besoin
soit parce que c'est des gens qui ont
déjà probablement très probablement
coronavirus et on veut juste que
vraiment le vérifier soit parce que
c'est du personnel médical et il faut
vraiment protéger le personnel médical à
tout prix faire en sorte qu'ils
travaillent dans les meilleures
conditions possibles parce que le
personnel médical c'est ultra critique
en ce moment alors mes pensées vont
énormément à eux parce qu'ils sont
boulot énorme affaire met donc vous qui
ne pourraient pas être dépistées bavard
fois résonné avec l'incertitude ya plein
de choses qu'on sépare toujours pas sûr
sur cette crise sur le court d'un virus
les risques de rechute les risques de
passer vous repreniez normal ce qu'ils
appellent une nouvelle épidémie qui va
reprendre encore de façon exponentielle
c'est compliqué est-ce que l'été pourra
être meilleur et des corrélations qui
suggère que peut-être avec plus de plus
de chaleur et d'humidité
le coroner il se propagera mois
peut-être peut-être pas on verra
summer is coming c'est d'espérer que
c'est une bonne nouvelle
je pense qu'on risque de vivre une crise
d'une ampleur qu'on n'a jamais connu
avant moi parce que falloir se serrer la
ceinture se serrer les coudes et je
pense que c'est plus importante que
jamais de faire preuve d'altruisme de
raisonnement parisien de hashtag bâton
mieux est de réfléchir à des algorithmes
plus robuste est bénéfique à tous et
c'est devenu ultra important donc plutôt
que d'y voir une open fatalité on peut
essayer de voir aussi une opportunité
c'est l'occasion de réfléchir beaucoup
plus à tous à deux mètres bien sûr tout
seul beaucoup plus en avant de réfléchir
beaucoup plus en termes de croissance
exponentielle de cas extrêmes de
raisonnement bayésiens et j'espère que
ça vous faire réfléchir
en tout cas je vais peut-être finir
aussi avec un message pro avant pour
vous' alors bien se passer
confinement va être un petit peu
difficile psychologiquement parce que
ces empreintes fois qu'on fait ça mais
il ya moins de se distraire de
de prendre ça un peu plus arrimé à la l2
liger voilà ce n'est plus le moment de
paniquer c'est pourquoi en plus moment
de faire paniquer non plus à non le
moment c'est de nous prendre le temps de
la réflexion réfléchir à tout ça de de
faire des activités plaisantes tout en
restant chez soi de ses deux passes et
un montant entre amir suisse car il peut
bien vieillir et toutes les plates
formes de de télétravail de youtube et
tout ça et tout cas j'espère que vous
prendrez vraiment soin de vous et
surtout que vous prendrez vraiment soin
de votre entourage
au revoir